le reste de l'actualité avec un français
encore enlevé au liban
roger auque un journaliste de 31 ans qui
travaille pour plusieurs médias français
a été enlevé devant son domicile à
beyrouth ouest
quelques minutes après qu'il ait
rencontré terry wet l'hémisphère
britannique chargé du problème des
otages justement pierre serra terry wey
tu es de retour à beyrouth pour tenter
d'obtenir la libération d'otages ce
matin vers 8 heures au jai ho que l'on
voit ici faisant son métier de
photographe était avec lui sur la
corniche de beyrouth
c'est plus tard vers 9h que l'enlèvement
a eu lieu écoutez le témoignage de paul
marchand photographe car il faillit être
enlevé lui le type à la kalach m'a pris
par la veste
il m'a dit en anglais suis moi moi j'ai
commencé à me débattre et j'ai vu une
grange et qui était de l'autre côté u2
qui tourne dans le minimum et le hall
d'un immeuble fermé par une grille et il
a vu et joue je me vis maths et je
frappais l'union tipiak a lâché je me
suis surpassé repas ne bouge pas sort
pas et il n'a pas compris si je crois
que la prophétie s'est passé tu parce
que lui il crié mais qu'est ce qui se
passe mais qu'est ce que vous faites
qu'est ce que vous faites et les sorties
il a ouvert la grille il essentiellement
dans l'autre type la mine pesoli sa tête
chez vue qui se débattait aussi projet
au 31 ans est en poste à beyrouth depuis
il est ce soir le sixième otage français
au liban son enlèvement n'a pas encore
été revendiqué en france